[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Hi.
>> Thank you so much for joining us for
the first view from the top of the year.
Marcos, Herman, Solio, we are excited
that you can help kick it off for
us during your 20th year reunion, no less.
Actually, I believe the class
of 1999 is in the building.
Can you guys make some noise so
we know you're here?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Okay, So
I thought we could start by taking
a brisk walk down memory lane.
I prepared a little flashback
Friday photo of you guys.
Can we queue that photo, please?
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is an early Mercado Libre team
shot, circa 1999.
What I love about this one is as you guys
can see startup founder co fashion hasn't
really evolved since then.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So A for consistency.
Okay, we are going to jump right in
because we have three times as much wisdom
to extract today.
I want to start by talking through
your academic and career journeys.
You each have very unique paths that
led you to Mercado Libre and beyond.
Marcus, we'll start with you.
You have a background in finance and
economics with a degree
from the Wharton School.
But you also almost played
professional rugby.
So tell us what was going on there,
you pass up the opportunity to play for
the national team.
Is it because you knew you were
destined for entrepreneurship?
>> [LAUGH] No, I think it's probably
because I knew I wasn't going to be that
good of a rugby player.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Okay, Hernan,
you did brand managements
at Procter & Gamble,
financial analysis at the UN, cofinder
MercadoLibre then started a VC firm.
What did you want to be when you grew up
and what was the moment that you figured
out, okay,
this is what I am supposed to be doing?
>> I think,
I always wanted to be an entrepreneur.
There was something that I Imagined
it happening later in my life.
And I think that being here at Stanford,
that particular moment in time also
having met Marcos and everything,
accelerated that really 20 years, and
ended up happening right after graduation.
>> Can you tell us the story?
How did you all meet?
>> So-
>> And I met before Stanford actually.
And we became friends here at school.
We're a group of Latin Americans always
discussing about the things that we
should be doing about the Internet,
this Internet thing that was starting.
And obviously no one was ever doing
anything at some point in time.
We said, why don't we just go and do it?
>> We're also arguing about soccer and
who was the best.
We got that going on as well,
I should say.
As a token Brazilian here.
>> We no longer discuss that,
unfortunately.
>> Stileo, you have the highest number
of Stanford degree in this stage.
Can you tell us about the inspiration
from moving from the technical
world to the world of business
management and entrepreneurship?
>> Yeah, so I was really thinking about
finance before coming to Stanford,
joining Stanford and after Stanford.
The way I got to MercadoLibre
was through casual
meeting with Marcos at Lehman
brothers of all places.
Three months after graduating
from Stanford, he was visiting,
he was fundraising already.
>> Wow.
>> And we met and
I was convinced by his passion,
the passion that he had
to build this company.
I called him, and three weeks later,
I and my wife who's here,
moved from New York to Sao Paulo to
start the business there in Sao Paulo.
>> So today, we're going to dig deep into
themes of entrepreneurship and adversity.
But first, I want to start by taking
us back to where it all began.
So it's the spring of 1999.
Ricky Martin is
an international sensation.
The Euro was just invented.
It's overall a really good year.
Especially, because the idea for
MercadoLibre was just born.
Now it's a huge success.
It was worth almost 28 billion as of
the last time I checked this morning.
But can you take us back to day zero and
how did you get from day zero to day one?
What were some of the baby steps that
you took to execute while you were still
students on campus
leading up to graduation?
>> Well, first I spent a lot of time
in the library and that's where Stilio
became suspicious, because he wasn't
used to see me at the library, right?
The second time he saw me at the library,
he said,
I think you're planning something.
>> Onto something.
[LAUGH]
>> That's a true story, by the way.
So, yeah, I mean, obviously,
took the opportunity to drive
John Muse to the airport, as Dean.
Living was just saying and
was able to get some soft commitments
to start in the business.
Then I convinced Hernan.
Hernan was going to be the CEO of
another startup and I told him,
why don't you just do
the marketing plan for me?
I knew he would have.
Once I got him in,
he would never leave, so
I had to convince him some way or another.
And, yeah, so I tried to assemble
the team and do as much research and
tried to get as much commitments
to funding as possible.
>> Okay, and it couldn't have been
easy starting a company as students.
I want to dive a little bit deeper into
some of the team dynamics of starting
a company with your classmates.
I know many of us are in this situation
right now, or at least considering it.
And we're having very,
very tough conversations.
So can you please tell us, how did
you decide who was going to be CEO?
What was that equity
split conversation like?
What were those dynamics?
>> [LAUGH] I warned them ahead of
time about tough questions, so.
>> In our case, it was the first part,
which I think is the most important
part is you need to get along very well.
Hernan, myself, Marquino Santos was here,
was there and was also working with us.
We always hanged out together and
we spent a lot of time together.
So I knew that it was going to work well.
So I think you need to start a company,
obviously with somebody who compliments
you, but
also someone who you get along well with.
And then the equity split, etc.
They're all different kind of solutions.
In our case, I started it and then I was
going to be CEO at different company.
I convinced him to do the marketing plans
and then we agreed on an equity package.
Let's say you shouldn't do what
our competitors from Harvard did.
They were 10 guys and
they split 10% each, so
each one had 10% of the company and
it didn't work out very well for them.
>> Tell us more about
those Harvard competitors.
[LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I know you love this story, Hernan.
>> It was interesting because
if there's one thing that it was
very innovative,
the idea because at the time we launched.
There were like 80 other companies
throughout Latin America more or
less following the same business model.
The difference in the case of
MercadoLibre was long term visual and
assembling a great team, the kind of
commitment that that team had, etc.
But not the idea per say.
And in particular,
there was this other Dean from Harvard
that started right at the same time.
It's a funny story because we organized
our launching ceremony in Buenos Aires and
just out of coincidence,
those guys had Reserved the same place
the following day or the day before.
I don't remember how it was, and they
were sure that we did that on purpose,
but it was just a coincidence,
and we started competing.
They ended up raising initially
more capital than we did,
so they had some advantage.
But their focus was more on marketing,
on trying really
to hit some initial milestones and
go public very soon.
While ours was more around
trying to build a technology,
trying to bring build organic engine for
growth and ended up paying out well.
In particular, when at the time we
started my career was when everything
was really colorful, then everything
went into gray after the bubble burst.
And that when you started to see their
big big difference between the two teams.
And a few years later we
ended up buying that company
a refraction of the capital
they had raised in the market.
>> So, Stanford, Harvard.
>> There you go.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I want to get your thoughts
on the team dynamics because, as MBAs,
we often hear that we're too type A and
you shouldn't start a company
with multiple MBA co-founders
because it will be too intense.
What was it like for you joining the team
and building a company with your friends?
>> Yeah,
I think it was a great experience.
And for me, the fact that I was in
Brazil and I had a clear mandate,
which was to build the business
there gave me some leeway.
Obviously, we interacted a lot.
So there's balance there between having
the chance to really hire my team,
build my team, but
also work together with my friends.
>> So I want to stay on our GSB
experience a little bit because it's so
relevant to many of us here.
Stileo, what specifically in
those two years really shaped you
as a business leader?
What did you experience?
What did you learn?
>> Yeah, so I, typically, when I speak
to students say don't follow my example.
>> Okay.
>> Which is good.
I mean at least, it's something that
people should learn which is I was
very much focused on finance.
I came to Stanford already with
a background in finance but
not with the knowledge with a theory.
And so I took all finance classes,
some really PhD level classes and
the like, and ended up working my summer
in finance and then after school as well.
And don't do that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Really, please, don't.
This is the chance for
you to experiment for you to go outside.
What is your comfort zone
to try different classes,
really learn skills that you don't have.
But I think the most important thing is
building relationships, and that I did,
and that's why we're here,
I guess, telling this story.
>> That's great.
Stileo just mentioned building
relationships, and I know Dean told
the story of how professor Jack McDonald
really helps in the beginning.
When you think about the people who
had your back while you were here,
who were those champions and
how did you develop and
cultivate those relationships over time?
>> Well, obviously for me, that class
from Jack McDonald was very important.
I had used my silver bullet for
his class, and in those days,
you had to use your silver bullet.
I spend most of my time
here going to class.
I really enjoyed going to class but
I didn't spend that much time studying for
exams and things like that.
>> At the library.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or at the library.
So I really enjoyed because Jack McDonald
would bring amazing guests to his lessons.
That's why I use his silver bullet.
I would always sit in the front row.
Once I got into the class and
it was early, I always got in early to get
into the front row, and
there was a guy just sitting at the table.
And it was just him and me for
like two, three minutes,
and he said I'm Joe Doe, I just
dressed up like Warren Buffet today.
And I had no idea who he was, so
I didn't understand the joke either, and
the guy was Warren Buffet.
And I was looking for
funding for my company, so
then eventually,
our classmates started to walk in.
I realized everybody recognized the guy,
the class started, it was a great class.
And then after the class, I told Jack
McDonnell, Jack, I want to do a startup.
I'm looking for
someone to fund this company.
And I spent three minutes with
Warren Buffett alone in the class and
wasn't even able to pitch him.
Next time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Next time someone like this comes
through, let me know.
I will [LAUGH] I will
attend your classes anyhow.
I am always there in the front row.
And he said, don't worry,
he would have invested anyhow.
He doesn't invest in Latin America but
these guys,
they have lots of investments
in Latin America.
I would tell this guy about
you during lunch, and
I would set you up to drive him
to the airport after class.
So that relationship with Jack McDonald
really worked out very well for me.
>> That's amazing.
Hernan, what were your most salient
GSB memories of support and rejection?
Those are two incredibly common and
useful experiences for self-growth but
I don't think the latter is often
discussed, so please share with us.
>> Being generally to an amazing
amazing experience for
me, was very eye-opening in all senses.
In terms of meeting these many people with
such great ambitions, really amazing.
And also for us, it was, again,
at a very particular moment in time
where we basically presented us
to the technology opportunity.
That was happening here and
it made us realized that nobody
knew anything about the Internet.
So we're all starting in
a level playing field,
and that gave young professionals
with really lots of energy and
willingness to change the world,
to start doing things.
>> In any other industry would
have been much more difficult and
I think that's why when they said I want
to be an entrepreneur in about 10 years 20
years from now is because I thought
you needed first to build something,
that is not what I wanted.
But what I always regret from my days
here is that it was only a 24-hour day.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There were many things to do.
All the opportunities to
be present with speakers,
in classes with amazing professors,
discussing things with classmates,
and you could not do all of them.
It's a challenge, so
they all opportunities are amazing.
It's about what you don't do and how you
make the best decisions best on that.
And it's difficult.
I think it's something
that them as managers,
as business leaders,
we keep on facing what not to do.
I think that is what a regr, in general,
has been an amazing experience and
incredible journey and
to be here sharing this with
some of our other classmates and
current students is also incredible.
I was thinking earlier kind of a joke but
I remembered I was in this very
similar event with Steve Jobs.
I know it's just the three to five here so
[LAUGH].
You go devalued is
the Argentinian Peso [LAUGH].
[LAUGH] Well, when you talk about
that time what you were here at GSP,
it seems like it was such
the momentous occasion and
the time to really jump
into entrepreneurship.
At least, that's what it seems.
But, Marcos,
you have this great quote that says,
they got tired of telling me that
my idea was not going to work.
>> Yes.
>> How did you find the tenacity to take
that leap of faith despite overwhelming
voices at the time telling you not to
move back to Latin America after the GSB?
>> Yeah.
>> And what advice do you have for us?
I'm looking at the NBA teams right now
who are going to make similar decisions,
many of which require us
to go against the green.
>> Well, everybody, everyone here at the
GSB, all of the Latin students are new and
everybody said this is never
going to work in Latin America.
Never in Latin America someone is going to
buy a product they haven't seen or
touched to someone they don't know.
Because this was happening in Germany,
in Japan and in the US.
This type of business model and
said this is for
this type of cultures, so
these won't work in our culture.
And I was convinced it was going to work.
Partly because having been
a Latin American who studied in the US,
I realize how Latin Americans behave
when they're in Latin America but
then how they behave when they're
here in a system that works well.
So I just knew that we needed to create
a system that works well with clear rules
and regulations.
And I was convinced,
that didn't discourage me at all.
Actually, I was a little bit naive
because I thought, this is great.
Everybody thinks it's not going to work.
There won't be that much competition,
which as [INAUDIBLE] said before,
it was a mistake.
There was a lot of competition.
But I would say as an advice,
I would certainly try to take risks.
If you have a view of something
that is a contrarian view but
it makes sense to you, just pursue it.
But then you need to be very resilient and
long term focused.
I mean there's a lot of
bumps down the road and
you need to be very resilient
because the bumps can be very tough.
You need to have a great team and that's
what the relationships of the GSB for me.
And for us, we're amazing.
We still have many GSBers working for
us for over 20 years.
So, you need a great team because
you cannot do it alone and
it's also more fun if
you have a great team.
But try to be contrarian with a view
that you really believe in and
just take risks and hold on to it.
>> And you could say that the contrarians
held that view because they were thinking
about the economic landscape of the market
at the time on what they perceived
were challenges.
Today, when we look at Silicon Valley and
other parts of the world,
it's saturated with every type
of start up under the sun.
But when you guys started in
Latin America, that was not the case.
There wasn't really a big culture
of tech entrepreneurship.
VC dollars were not flowing
the way they are flowing today.
So how did you convince investors
to give you money back then?
How did you make decisions
without not too much data?
>> Yeah, it was hard.
I mean, we started with VCs, and
actually investment banks invested in us.
Which was a big problem later on
because after the bubble burst,
some of them got cold feet and
they wanted to shut down the company.
So we had to fight with our [COUGH]
shareholders not to shut down the company.
We had to go to a shareholder vote, and
we were pretty close to losing that vote
because given that we had raised a lot
of money and unlike our competitors,
we hadn't spent that money.
Some of our shareholders said,
let's shut down this company and
take the money out, and it's going to be
the only investment in which at least we
will not have lost the money.
[LAUGH] So, yeah, when you get
investors that are not used to risk,
it's not the best thing, but
it's the only thing we could get.
Fortunately, now we have funds like
Hernan's that are funding lots of
entrepreneurs.
And really, entrepreneurship has
taken off, and there are VCs,
there are many organizations
that help entrepreneurs.
So it's a very different landscape
today than what it was 20 years ago.
>> Well if we fast forward,
you just celebrated 20 years
of Mercado Libre's success.
And during that time, you navigated and
thrived through multiple crises,
both here in the States and
in Latin America.
Even IPOing during one of those crises.
And you were the first Latin American
company to be listed on the NASDAQ.
That's incredible.
Stileo, what have been the values
that you have held dear in the past
two decades that have enabled you to
brace the ups and downs of this time?
>> Yeah, so I mentioned when I met
Marcos that one time at Lehman Brothers
when I was convinced that I wanted to
join, there was passion in his eyes.
When I spoke to Hernan later,
I also saw that same passion,
and I think there is a sense
of purpose in what we do.
We saw that technology was
changing people's lives and
it was going to change people's lives.
I think what Marcos was saying,
this sort of contrarian view was
that there was going to be impact.
Maybe the people that said
no were the people that
were just seeing things
the way they were back then.
And we were seeing things
sort of beyond that.
And I think that sense of purpose,
that technology can change people's
lives when we think of what we
do as an e-commerce marketplace.
The number of entrepreneurs actually
that have built businesses on top
of our platform.
We're now also going into fintech and
I think there's tremendous
opportunity with financial services,
democratizing financial services.
So those I think are values
that have kept us together and
having that long term vision as well.
>> Hernan, you were at Mercado Libre and
then you left to Found Cosmic ventures.
When you look back at the last 20
years from your GSB time to now,
what has been the single most
difficult part of that journey?
>> Difficult part I think, going back to
a couple of instances in our career days.
One was when we tried to close
our second round of financing,
which we ended up closing.
But we closed that one in May 2000,
and the bubble burst in March 2000.
So I remember at the time we had
like probably 10 term sheets or
10 investors really interested
in investing in the company.
And as days went by,
one investor will drop out and
another one another one another one, and
we ended up with one final investor.
I remember organized a call with
us to discuss the marketing
plan of which was a very
tiny operation in America.
We have the time management, well,
why do they want to do this?
And we went into the meeting,
kind of hesitating what to say and
basically, those investors,
they were also dropping out.
So we're left with nothing.
Somehow, I don't know, each one of
those say, games I do play 20 times.
And probably,
you end up losing most of the them.
But we would turn it around,
I think again, in persistence and
also some help from the investors that
were inside the company at the time.
We ended up closing that round, but
that was a very tough time for us.
I remember we used to get in a room
together and say what the heck,
what can we do?
And then we would walk out the room and
say, hey, guys, everything's fine.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's terrible because also our
competitors were doing a lot of marketing
and they were Everybody, even our friends,
our competitors were called the remata.
And even my friends would say,
so how's the remata doing?
And we were like, no,
ours is MercadoLibre.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So at night, we would lock up ourselves
up in a room and we were like, okay,
let's release our anguish now between us.
And then we would leave the room and
everything is good, but it was.
>> We'll close around [LAUGH].
>> Yes, it was very, very tough.
>> That was a tough time of what
Marcos described of that voting.
I think was the only time that the board
ever voted for something in MercadoLibre.
We're kind of sleeping with the enemy, who
were happy that the company was evolving
and our own shareholders
wanted to shut it down.
>> I want to dig deeper into the nuances
of building a business in Latin America.
We know now that there's so much
opportunity, MercadoLibre has proved that,
Kaszek Ventures has proven that.
But we also keep hearing about all of
these challenges, perceived challenges.
Which of these challenges
would you say are missed that
you are tired of hearing about?
And which of those would you say,
truly these are aspects in which
the region is still behind?
>> I would say all
the stereotypes are true.
>> Okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was trying to use a narrative but-
>> All the challenges are there, no,
it's true.
>> Give us some examples.
>> It's tough, it's very tough.
Infrastructure is not as developed,
regulations are backwards.
Many times, regulators are not thinking
for the benefit of most of the people.
They're just trying to optimize for
themselves.
So it's very few times,
you encounter an environment
which is very pro-business and
pro-growth, etc,
which it's part of the game,
so you need to deal with that.
And at the end of the day,
if you are able to deal with that,
the opportunity is still just as big.
But you need to understand that
the environment is not necessarily
a pro-business environment, and
it changes and it's very volatile.
So, all of a sudden then you have
elections and a new government comes in,
and it's great, and
it lasts for a few years.
And then a different government
comes in and they change everything.
I would say except for Chile, which is
a country that has been very stable and
growing very, very well for many years.
The rest of Latin America is very volatile
and it's challenging to do business there.
>> I'd say the flip side to that is that
it requires you to have a lot of patience,
a lot of resilience, because otherwise,
it would be easy and
probably a lot of people
would be doing the same.
So for us, having to deal with all that
frustration of dealing with government,
with tax regimes, with unions, with all
the difficulties we have, makes it harder.
>> It definitely makes it seem like it is
a lot harder than building a company here.
What do you think the developed
world can learn from startups and
entrepreneurship in emerging markets,
Stileo?
>> I think it has to do with that,
that a lot of companies that go
into Latin America, for example.
They go with some ideas of how
things work in their home markets,
and those aren't necessarily the same.
I like to say that e-commerce,
for example, is extremely local.
We need to integrate with payment
providers from each respective country,
even from MercadoLibre which is
in 18 countries in Latin America.
The fact that you integrate with
Visa in Brazil means nothing for
Visa and in Argentina.
You need to do something specific
in each of those markets.
So logistics is very local.
So the challenges are really
not to just bring a model that
works in your home market and
expect it to work local.
I think that's true of
all emerging markets.
>> Hernan, can we get your opinion on
this localization topic now that you're
on the other side as an investor
working with startups?
What advantages does a local
incumbents player have in the market
when in an international,
big western player comes in?
I'm thinking about Amazon's aggressive
attempts to enter the region.
Are there benefits unique to
the indigenous players in these parts of
the world?
>> That's a central part of our
investment, strategy in Casick.
We only invest in businesses
where we think there are some,
what we call local friction points.
Something like what Stileo was describing,
because of payments or
because of logistics or,
in FinTech, because of regulation.
We are, again,
we're talking about technology.
So there are no absolute advantages.
So everything is very competitive.
But at least, if you are the local player
and you know how to operate logistics
there or you know how to get
the approval from the Central Bank,
that gives you an edge versus
the outside competitor.
That only has larger funds or
economic capacity but
does not get that final point so well.
So it's harder to develop that
if you are in the Bay Area or
if you're in China or
in another part of the world.
It's much easier to do it
from a local perspective.
You need to be great at it and that's your
advantage but I mean your disadvantage is
that your global competitor has better
access to financing or other things.
So you really need to make sure
you can overcompensate for that.
I think clearly,
MercadoLibre has been an example of that.
And many of the companies we invest in try
to follow that same path not only to have
large businesses, but those businesses
where the fact that you are local,
and that you are operating from the local
market gives you an edge there.
>> Marcos, in your experience,
what would you say is the biggest
mistake that an entrepreneur in
an emerging market can make?
>> Overspending, probably, and
not focusing on building a great product.
What we've seen a lot is entrepreneurs
imitating this model that you see a lot in
developed markets where you
have a lot of access to funds.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Like stories like
the ones we're reading
in the newspapers now.
We work for, just to say one or Uber.
They've raised billions and
billions of capital.
It's very rare that you can raise
that much money in emerging markets.
But at some point in time, there is a lot
of liquidity in emerging markets, so
people raise a lot of money in
those points in those times.
And they try to recreate that strategy
of spending and eventually we will
figure out the business, and
eventually we will figure out the product.
And I've never seen one of those
stories succeed in the region.
I've seen many, the entrepreneurs that we
see succeeding are the ones that are very
focused on the product, in the team.
Obviously, when the opportunity
comes to raise money or
you try to raise as much as you can, but
then try to administer that capital well.
Because the stories of racing a lot
of money and funding deficit for
many, many years are very unlikely
to succeed in emerging markets.
The funding window always ends up
closing at some point in time.
>> But now we have so
many more of those success stories.
Earlier we talked about how the landscape
wasn't there when you guys first started.
>> Yeah.
>> But now there is this huge culture of
tech entrepreneurship and
it's thriving in part due to
the work that you all have done.
Marcos you're on the board
of Endeavor Global.
>> Yep.
>> Focusing on long-term economic growth
by working with entrepreneurs, and
Hernan Kaszek Ventures' mission is to
work with technology
start-ups in Latin America.
For those of us who are interested
in building entrepreneurial and
technology ecosystems in
other parts of the world or
even parts to the US that have largely
been ignored by the innovation train.
What would you say are the foundational
things that you've helped
implement in Latin America that we need
to focus on to foster innovation and
impact in other parts of the world?
>> I think having a success
case is very important.
I mean, I see what Marco Aleeri has
done for the region has been key,
because then many other
entrepreneurs can say, here,
we're going to be the next
Marco Aleeri and that helps a lot.
So try to build from a success story.
I think that is very helpful,
particularly if you are from a region
that is not associated with tech or
with entrepreneurship.
Try to create I think Israel has done
that and now they have many, many,
many success stories.
But they started with one,
and then another one.
The first it was Wayze and then etc.
But so try to start with one success case
and build from there, I think that's,
I don't know Amari you want-
>> I think what clearly the tech ecosystem
in Latin America has evolved a lot,
in our early days, there was nothing.
We just took advantage of that small
window when investment bankers
wanted to provide some
capital to startups.
But then after that, there was
a desert for many, many years and
then slowly but steadily,
opportunities started to to appear.
Clearly successful cases that can
inspire the next generation of
entrepreneurs is very important.
I think that having a few investors
that can really help those
companies take off with some
advice is very, very useful.
Obviously you have to have
the underlying tailwind of technology
entering the market.
Maybe not at the most accelerated pace,
that was something I remember that
used to happen in our early days.
We're always growing at a very fast rate,
but never at 500, 1,000% per year.
In the initial days of our relationship
with E-Bay, that became for a time
a share holder of Marco Aleeri, they were
saying they were looking at the typical
charts and seeing a year one for eBay year
one for Marco Aleeri, year two for eBay.
And during those years we were
growing much faster they would say.
I said hey this is what we can do
today because of infrastructure,
because of Internet penetration but
we think that we're going to have
a much longer growth trajectory,
because up until we reach the kind of
population penetration that we want,
it'll take us longer, but we'll get there.
And I think, that at that time,
people did not buy that.
But that is what ended up happening,
Marco Aleeri is still today keeps
on growing at amazing rates.
And all the other comparables
grew much faster initially, but
then they plateau, and that has happened.
So obviously, you need to have that
underlying force that is driving that
ecosystem, and then be patient.
Because everything we said happened
maybe it happened a little later
versus what we we thought I remember that
now the business plan we put together for
our second round of financing
ended up happening.
>> It still bid by the way.
>> We.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> We surpassed that big time by 35 years
later.
[LAUGH] So and we need to make sure
that you focus on the long run,
but I think in success cases,
investor that can help you there.
Marcos was mentioning regulation,
at least regulation that doesn't kill you.
It's important.
>> I would add one more thing
which is a culture of giving back.
And it's not just money, but time.
I think there is this
need of what did you do,
what happened in your case,
can you tell us your story?
I think that's something that
we've been doing a lot of,
and more people, other success
stories as well in Latin America.
Have been able to go back and
tell their story.
Obviously in some cases, also financing
these ventures, which is great.
>> We are going to wrap up with
our infamous lightning round,
that I warned you about earlier.
>> Great.
>> We're going to do a special iteration,
[LAUGH] I'm going to list a couple
of superlatives and you will point
to the person on your co-founding team
to who it most applies, you ready?
>> This is a first time
that you do a panel, right?
So-
>> This is the first time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> How did you do this in the past?
>> Most times, it's just like easy,
this or that questions, but
I had to give you guys something special.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay.
[LAUGH] Least likely to be RJ Miller?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Most likely to schedule
a call at 2:00 AM.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Do you agree?
[LAUGH] Most likely to know
all the lyrics to Despacito?
>> Whoa.
>> None of us [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH]
>> If there
was something in Portuguese,
maybe it would be me, yeah.
>> Now that was a crowdsourced one.
Most likely to never miss a football game?
>> Watching or playing?
>> Ooh, watching.
>> No.
>> Me?
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah Hernando.
>> Is it a tie?
>> I used to like football a lot but
not any longer, so.
>> I still do, I still do.
>> Okay, last one, you ready?
Most likely to buy something from eBay?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Nobody, I think that's
the perfect answer.
[LAUGH] Ladies and gentlemen,
please help me in thanking them.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
[MUSIC]